Here is my answer. Here is the expand command.
It takes the omega vector and turns it in to a 4 x 4
and assigns the existing coordinate to 0, 1, and 2
and expands to make xi vector of 4 x 1
where it uses the previous dimensions of 0, 1, 2, and 0.
That turns out to make a larger matrix and larger vector.
Now, I go and add in the measurement constraints.
In all of those, I have to relate to the last coordinate,
which is my measurement coordinate from the first, the second, and the third pose.
And I have to subtract -z0, 1, and 2 from the corresponding robot poses
and add them all up back to the last pose.
If you implement this correctly, then you get a omega and xi
that, once you implement this solution equation, gets you this solution over here.